bienvenue dans le queens à tous les
jeunes vous êtes dans l'aréna des
cavaliers l'équipe championne de
basket-ball ici yannick dumont baron
correspondant de radio canada à
washington
on est à cleveland parce que c'est la
convention républicaine c'est ma
première convention je voulais vous
montrer quelques trucs pour vous montrer
dans le fond concours une convention en
cours ont fait du camping politique
regardez ici vous reconnaissez sûrement
michel c'est roger christian latreille
regardez aussi les petites lignes
blanches par terre ça c'est l'espace
radio canada à côté c'est l'espace
cilicie faut pas dépasser céline ne peu
d'espacé pour faire de la télé on est
loin comme ça de la scène la scène que
vous voyez juste ici c'est là où nous
tromper les gens parlent aussi sur le
plancher les délégations qui sont là qui
arrivent tranquillement bientôt par état
on voit confirmer les votes
on va voter pour dans l'autre chante ici
vous voyez en eau près du jumbo seront
dans ce coin-là ici ce sont des ballons
des ballons des milliers des milliers de
ballons j'ai oublié combien c'est des
dizaines de milliers de ballons qu'on va
lancer jeudi soir lorsque selon toute
attente bien sûr dans notre monde va
accepter d'être le candidat des
républicains à la présidentielle en
novembre